nous inscrire dans une équipe de
natation synchronisée la natation
synchronisée masculine je préfère te
prévenir c'est pas donné à tout le monde
quoi foyer la volonté la grâce le rythme
et une grande hygiène de vie
tu te sens capable de ça
[Musique]
championnats du monde qu'est pour vol et
voilà qu on l affaire sur la musique
autres chorégraphies la mère de cette
[Musique]
équipe de france va comprend pas les
sommes dues aux fans
[Musique]
je t'ai demandé quelque chose garder
menton gras tels que l'argent de tes
potes
est ce que vous croyez c'est comme ça
que vous allez gagner juste participer à
des jeux pas entendu je suis participer
bien de rigoler vous allez toujours ma
tante et on va aller courir je peux mes
habits pour courir
[Musique]
tiens